here's the most effective way to give
someone a genuine compliment that hits
home so when I was in high school I was
walking with three friends and one
friend kept walking to a classroom right
around the corner and I assumed that
they had just continued to walk and
after they walked away I said something
nice about the guy to the friend that I
was with and what I didn't know is that
the friend who had walked around the
corner actually hadn't walked that far
and had sat down and tied his shoe and
he had been there and he overheard the
compliment that I had said about him and
so what ended up happening was I
realized that it was one of the only
ways that you can genuinely give someone
a compliment without them thinking that
you have something in store for them and
so one of the things that I've tried to
do in my life is if I'm walking away
let's say I'm walking out of a
restaurant or someone walks ahead of me
and they think that I think that they
can't hear me I will try and deliver the
compliments that I want to tell them but
I will say it to somebody else just loud
enough that they can hear me but don't
think that they can hear me because it
just hits so much different and so if
you ever have that opportunity to give
someone that gift I would recommend
doing it because it's really fulfilling